I want to show this chart here on where
billionaires were putting their monies
at okay if you can zoom into this
picture so we can look at because at the
end of the day 880 million dollars were
put in different packs by these
billionaires if you look at Soros 129
million dollars went into go a little
lower so we can see exactly what it's oh
I see it over here hang on one second so
I'm with you because I can't demonstrate
yeah in a democracy pack two okay you
got Sam uh bankman freed uh he's the guy
of FTS the guy that lost all the money
he wanted to give all his money to the
Democrats 39 million dollars went into a
few different things protect our future
pack color of change pack uh not color
of change pack it was mainly that and
then House Majority pack GMI pack
Elizabeth and Richard olhine gave a lot
of it to Club for Growth Action some to
Restoration pack Wisconsin Truth pack
and then he also put some money into
what's the last one there I can't see
the last one it goes into others Ken
Griffin in 66 million dollars Jeffrey
asked 48 Steven Schwartzman 38 33
million dollars into Congressional
leadership fund he put into Senate
leadership fund he put an American
leadership action and he put some of it
in others and then you had Peter Thiel
put 30 million into
protect Ohio values pack uh and then he
put into saving Arizona pack okay
obviously he was betting on you know Oz
and uh late JD Vance JD Vance that's
right that's right JD Vance and uh
that's right Oz is a Pennsylvania uh
Vance says Ohio which paid off and then
so a lot of billionaires are getting
involved the question becomes the
following is this a good thing or a bad
thing and will this ever stop like you
know for somebody that ran do you think
we can ever you know prevent these guys
from getting involved and if we did how
different would the election be I think
it's a bad thing and I have uh unclean
hands on this Ken Griffin gave me money
when I ran for governor
um pritzker the current governor who
worked for me he gave money to my
campaign when I ran for governor uh and
then after I had won
um and pritzker being the heir to the
height Hotel Fortune has spent tens of
millions of his own money to win
re-election the first time 175 million
dollars I don't know what he spent this
time probably more to win re-election
and so
I think look the Republicans spent more
than four billion dollars in this
election cycle 4 billion the Democrats
just about 4 billion
this is in this this is obscene and I
think really a problem for our democracy
what's the solution people don't like it
and this sounds like a Bernie Sanders
kind of approach but I feel like you
should limit the amount of money that
candidates can spend in campaigns I
think the broadcasting media should give
free advertising to candidates you got
to figure out who's a credible candidate
or not there's got to be some sort of
fair way to do that and I think they're
they're taxpayers might have a vested
interest in public financing of
campaigns and take the money out of it I
think what you're referring to is
obviously campaign Finance reform what
was it in 2010 that was the Supreme
Court ruling for Citizens United 2014 I
know that case real well because that's
why I went to prison and things like
that exactly I think that's been a
disaster for campaign and and big money
in politics and where you can basically
buy elections and we've seen here by
that chart we can pull it up it's on the
left and the right people are given
millions and millions and billions of
dollars and I mean whether you're a
Bernie Sanders guy or not
or an AOC person or not or a Marjorie
Taylor green or not
they're getting money by individual
donors rather than big
you know ridiculous billionaires that
can just basically influence and buy
elections I think that citizens united
decision by the Supreme Court has had a
very negative impact on America thank
you and I'm glad you said that I got to
add another thing though I thought this
at first was a good thing it's a bad
thing when Obama was going crazy in a
positive way and it was setting the
world on fire back in 2008 and he was
Raising small daughter contributions
from people all over the country and one
month he raised 100 million dollars that
was unprecedented and it was coming from
everyday people sending in Small Checks
my first thought was this is good for
democracy because what it's doing is
it's diluting the influence of the
special interest groups the Pacs and
those who do business around government
right and dilutes the influence of these
billionaires what it's done however is
Trump has now become and the Republicans
have become Grassroots fundraisers so
they've got their group of small dollar
donors what that does is it divides the
politics you can't now compromise with
the other side and keep your fundraising
base of all those people who like that
sort of extreme position or those hard
positions that some of them take and it
what it does is it discourages
compromise finding common ground and it
continues to polarize that country
that's why I think in my you know I
don't really know the full answer but I
know that ain't working the billionaires
ain't working uh there's too much money
in politics the campaign seasons are way
too long the the media makes all kinds
of money on the TV ads everybody has a
stake in this as Citizens I think
everybody should sacrifice including
taxpayers we should limit the amount of
money that's spent and these media
people should be able should have to be
able to do it for free and put some of
these ads on
um but I don't expect that any of that
will happen in the near the citizens
United decision in 2010 is there a
chance that that's brought up again in
in the Supreme Court again these days
how does that work yeah but it would
probably be even more reaffirmed by that
conservative court because they've taken
the position that and under the First
Amendment you have a right to give as
much as you want it's your money so a
lot of people will complain about George
Soros of the things that he's doing and
the negative ramifications
but isn't that tantamount to exactly
what this is it's like if you don't want
George Soros buying elections then don't
propose these citizens United's
amendments right or these bills
yes
so your question is what I'm just saying
like you're saying that if they did
revisit the citizens united ruling today
with the conservative Supreme Court that
are probably will reaffirm the decision
yeah so it's
essentially saying keep doing what
you're doing George Soros I mean you're
cool just think about it this way
somebody just commented right now Andrew
huff and gave ten bucks and he said Adam
Mark Zuckerberg bought the 2020
elections for the Democrats and split
over 400 million dollars on dropboxes
that's a lot of money to be used and
that's a lot of influence by the way
look what happened they lose 800 billion
dollars of valuation with Facebook the
guy loses a hundred billion dollars of
his net worth and they're letting they
announced today a day after elections
very appropriate day after midterm
election they're laying off 11 000
employees today nobody thought it was
going to be a number that big but all of
these things that are going on when you
guys are going back and forth talking
about this I don't know if I'm
comfortable with people putting that
kind of money into it and I don't really
know what would happen if the money was
out you would actually need to do the
workout shake hands talk to people
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]